في هذا المكان هي نقطه الدفاع المدني او
مكتب الدفاع المدني الذي كان يعمل ليل
نهار لانقاذ حياه وارواح المواطنين الان
هذه النقطه مدمره وسيارات الدفاع المدني
في هذا المكان او في داخل منطقه التفاح
ونقطه النافور هذه النقطه المركزيه الان
سيارات الدفاع المدني ونقطه الدفاع المدني
مدمره بشكل كامل هذه الرافعه هي من
الرافعات الوحيده التي دخلت بمساعده قطريه
الان هذه الرافعه هي خارج الخدمه ومد
ولا يمكن استخدامها فيما بعد بسبب
احتراقها هذا المكان هو ضمن منطقه التفاح
هذا المكان مدمر هذه بركسات تابعه لتجار
بركسات ومخارط وحتى البنايات السكنيه ايضا
مدمره هذه البنايه للاسف محترقه ومدمره
بالكامل هذا بركس
تجاري ويحتوي على شاحنات تجاريه وشاحنات
نقل ايضا مدمر الدمار اصلا بده حدا يحكي
عليه انت شايف الدمار وين المكان وكل قطاع
غزه هذا امر تهجير مش دمار يعني لاي حاجه
لا بده يهجروا الناس من بيوتها هذه واحده
وهي الدور قدامكم البريه ما صمدت يعني ما
سلمت من الدمار جرفو كل هيتها الدور محتها
محلاتنا حرقتها بيتنا نزلته هذا كان محل
زيوت
سيارات شايف محل زيوت سيارات هنا كان
فناتر وزيوت سيارات ملانه احنا بنعيش هنا
يا بنموت ما فيش امكانيه يعني كل اللي صار
بدنا ننام ه بعملي خم هنا بعملي عريشه
وبنام فيها هنا لا باقون فش امكانيه يعني
ال هان ولدش ت حداده مع مخر والي هان
مستودع لبيع الحديد
للبنا ايش اللي
تدمر شايف في عندي فوق 300 طن حديد ه مش
مبينين عندي كبشين ه معزين فطر مغادي
مدحله تاع شوارع مكسره معزوجه في فضر بغال
روح يشد على المقاومين هيهم هيهم شرقه هي
شرقه صب حاجه المقاومين قدر ز المقاومين
هو لانه ندل هو واتباعه ومن قابله شارون
بدهم يهجرنا يا حج هم بدهم يرحل نن بحلش ع
الموت بنحل ننا صامدين على هذه الارض نطع
منها بالمره لو حتى هدموا هدموا البيوت
فوق روس ما بنطلع منها هذ ارضنا وارض جداد
ما بنطلع منها بالمره يعني فينا طفل صغير
يرضع ما بنطلع منها هذا ارضنا وارض
اجدادنا واحنا واحنا مع المقاومه ومع مع
مع القسام ومعهم كلهم هذول هذه منطقه
التفاح والدرج التي دمرت بفعل قوات
الاحتلال يصر الاهالي على البقاء بداخلها
والرفض لمخطط التهجير رغم كل المحاولات
القصريه التي تعاملت معها قوات الاحتلال
من داخل مدينه غزه اسماعيل الغول قناه
الجزيره مدينه غزه